stop
the most important thing is to never
stop questioning albert einstein
stop
stop writing proposals stop following up
with people stop hiring salespeople
instead be like brian hull
who
brian hall released a youtube video of
himself to singing let it go from the
movie frozen in the voices of disney and
pixar characters
in less than two weeks brian's video has
almost 10 million views
what does this have to do with you
now i don't know brian hill personally
but let's assume he's trying to make it
as a singer or cartoon voiceover artist
how can he make it he's in a super
competitive field like you
everyone is all saying and doing the
same things are you
the way for brian to get noticed isn't
to write proposals or constantly follow
up with his leads or hire a salesperson
it's to show off his amazing talents in
a way that his target audience will say
wow and can't help but share
brian has already gotten a call from
disney to come in others are calling
with opportunities as well
what can you do
for a brief moment please forget
everything you've learned about sales go
on this journey with me
imagine for a moment that instead of
doing the stuff that you hate proposal
writing calling leads and so on
what if you could pour your talents into
something that would be amazing to your
target audience and make them want to
share it and call you
which would you enjoy more which would
have a greater impact which would make
you feel like you're doing something
important
you're talented at least i hope you are
if you're not talented and using sales
as a way to compensate for your weakness
then i can't help you
but you should be among the best at what
you do in the world that's what
successful entrepreneurs are so find a
way to capture what you're great at and
will impact your audience you don't need
10 million views on a video you just
need your target audience to witness
what you made and say wow
that's it
now get to work
believe
you